hey this is the best
donald trump
flipped out because a jury has acquitted
hillary clinton's lawyer this if you
haven't been following this story
this is the absolute best former hillary
clinton campaign attorney michael
sussman
has been acquitted of lying to the fbi
about donald trump and russia during the
2016 election
this was supposed to be the big smoking
gun trump was talking about this others
have been talking about this with regard
to the 2016 election we were finally
going to get the proof of everything
hillary did to me during my campaign as
trump liked to say and the verdict
indeed is that uh mr sussman has been
acquitted a clinton campaign lawyer
michael sussman found not guilty of
lying to the fbi in a blow to the durham
investigation trump's been talking about
this durham investigation for months and
months and months
a hillary clinton campaign lawyer
michael sussman was acquitted of lying
to the fbi the first trial of special
counsel john durham's investigation the
verdict is a major defeat for durham and
as justice department prosecutors who
have spent three years looking for
wrongdoing in the trump-russia probe he
claimed sussman lied during a 2016
meeting in which he passed a tip to the
fbi about trump and russia the jury
deliberated for six hours over two days
and revolt and uh uh reached a verdict
the case revolved around
uh sussman's 2016 meeting with james
baker a friend who was the fbi's general
counsel sussman passed along a tip which
led to a four-month fbi inquiry into a
possible internet back channel between
the trump organization and the
kremlin-linked alpha bank both companies
denied the claim the fbi found no
improper cyber links so here is uh
sussman speaking about the verdict and
then i'm going to show you how trump
flipped out i have a few thoughts to
share now the trial has ended
first
i told the truth to the fbi
and the jury clearly recognized that
with their unanimous verdict today
i'm grateful to the members of the jury
for their careful and thoughtful service
despite being falsely accused i'm
relieved that justice ultimately
prevailed in my case so this is called
due process
and trump absolutely flips out on his
platform truth social truth essential
saying our legal system is corrupt our
judges and justices are highly partisan
compromised or just plain scared our
borders are open our elections are
rigged inflation is rampant gas prices
and food costs are through the roof our
military leadership is woke our country
is going to hell
and michael sussman is not guilty how's
everything else doing
enjoy your day
this was a jury that acquitted him this
was the people if they are for law and
order and due process
then this man is not guilty due process
has taken place it has been adjudicated
remember when trump said that durham's
case was going to be bigger than
watergate and it was going to expose the
biggest political crime of the century
which when asked trump said you know
what it is he wouldn't even say what it
was obama gate
none of these things are anything and
fox news immediately running with the oh
the jury the jury the jury was in dc it
was a bad jury
this is due process and they don't like
the outcome take a look at this but it
was given the auspice of being true not
because of a media report but because of
an fbi investigation into president
trump and at the center of that was the
susman
meeting um and michael sussman the
prosecutor in this case britain shaw
argued that he wanted a quote october
surprise that that was at the the heart
of his intentions it doesn't appear that
the jury bought that but i think david
spunt raises a key point harris the dc
jury pool this is a area of our country
where 76 percent of people in the
district of columbia are registered
democrat this was a jury pool of 37 that
was whittled down to a smaller number
but of those 37 jurors there were many
about clinton supporters who said they
had donated to the clinton campaign
some of those individuals weren't chosen
but about a third of that jury pool was
either a clinton supporter or had strong
feelings about the election listen
in every case
in the written house case in in any case
there's always
some beliefs on the jury
that might
superficially seem in some way
adversarial to one side or the other but
we have a process for jury selection
during which people are asked do you
think you can fairly evaluate the facts
and if the facts point this way or that
way you would be able and people say yes
i would or no i wouldn't it's the same
jury selection process you have anywhere
and this is an absurd post-hoc
justification um and prosecutors were
very frustrated that they would not get
a fair shake here so i think this does
raise questions on how fair of a shake
you can be given in dc with the jury
pool that does oftentimes weigh
partisanly in one direction you can't
prosecute republicans in washington d.c
washington d.c is let me see washington
dc
republic uh democrat
percentage
um
i guess it's like roughly 70 something
percent i mean you ca no republican
uh led prosecution
uh and no democratic
um defendant can be fairly evaluated
because there's just too many democrats
in washington d.c this is essentially
what they are saying these people are
shameless
they are only concerned with the
consequences this is the due process
they claim to be about this is the law
and order they claim to be about the
durham investigation was allowed to
happen nobody interfered with it they
were able to bring charges
they were able to show we have at least
probable cause or suff probable cause
maybe is the wrong term
the the judge said there's enough here
to move forward and have a trial
you got a jury prosecution and defense
were allowed to evaluate the jury they
settled on a jury they had the trial
they had deliberations they had a
verdict
it was in dc of course he was acquitted
of course he was acquitted they will
never be satisfied with law and order
if it doesn't give them the outcome that
they want and uh i mean is this it for
for the durham probe probably not
but we are going to continue to follow
it it's not feeling like the durham
investigation is going to expose the
so-called biggest crime of the century
it's it's not my sense that that's the
direction that it's going let me know
we'll be posting these stories on our
facebook page facebook.com
david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
what if you could get through an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top non-fiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient i just used blinkist to listen
to the book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist.com pacman to try
blinkist free for seven days and you'll
get 25 off a premium subscription that's
just 625 a month
the link is down below